Black Panther Wakanda Forever arrive ce
1er février 2023 sur Disney plus un bon
moyen de le voir si vous avez loupé sa
sortie au cinéma ou tout simplement le
revoir depuis chez vous malheureusement
avec les géo restrictions le film ne
sera pas disponible en France avant un
bon moment c'est là que j'ai une
solution à vous proposer vous l'aurez
compris cette vidéo est sponsorisée par
North VPN avec nordvpn en un seul clic
vous pouvez changer votre localisation
depuis n'importe où pour accéder au
contenu de n'importe quel endroit si
vous êtes en France et que vous désirez
voir Black Panther Wakanda Forever et
bien changé votre localisation pour par
exemple le Canada et cela vous permettra
d'avoir accès au film sur disney+
d'ailleurs le SERVICE nordvpn vous
propose un accès sur plus de 6 appareils
différents donc de quoi en faire
profiter votre entourage grâce à ses
5200 serveurs répartis dans plus de 60
pays différents vous aurez une très
bonne vitesse d'exécution et tout ça de
manière sécurisée car Nord VPN est un
outil qui vous protège également contre
les criminels et la surveillance sur le
web si vous êtes intéressé n'hésitez pas
à accéder aux liens disponibles en
description nordvpn vous propose une
offre de deux ans avec une grosse
réduction et un mois offert satisfait ou
remboursé sur 30 jours merci à norvpn
que la vidéo commence
[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette première véritable vidéo de
2023 le titre de la vidéo doit quelque
peu vous surprendre et c'est tout à fait
normal j'aimerais tout simplement
aujourd'hui que nous passions à la
vitesse supérieure cela fait un moment
que je vous parle d'une vidéo dédiée aux
dimensions de Marvel je crois que cela
fait depuis le pourquoi Dormammu est-il
si unique et en fait depuis toujours
l'une des grandes clés pour moi du futur
de Marvel ou plutôt bas du MCU et bien
cela réside dans ce sujet la phase 4 qui
symbolise le renouveau de la saga
cinématographique nous a énormément
amené sur ce sujet Talo dans shankshi le
TVA ou encore la fin des temps dans Loki
le cap junction les possibles enfers
dans Doctor Strange 2 la dimension Nour
dans Miss Marvel le sanctuaire
d'éternity dans Thor love and sender une
dimension quelconque où se trouve des
démons dans she Hulk bref et on n'oublie
pas bien évidemment le chant quantique
qui sera exploitée de en comble dans ant
Man 3 de plus en plus les dimensions
arrivent au cœur de la saga et ce n'est
pas du tout un hasard les dimensions
possèdent une importance capitale et
pourrait expliquer pas mal de choses
concernant l'avenir du MCU je parle bien
évidemment de the Kang dynastie et
Secret Wars et en plus de cela une
récente News a fait son apparition je ne
vous ai jamais trop fait part de cette
supposition car j'attendais cette vidéo
pour le faire et surtout j'avais besoin
de maîtriser mon sujet c'est pourquoi on
en parle que maintenant mais il
s'avérerait que Docteur Strange 3 serait
apparemment prévu pour sortir entre the
Kong dynastie et Secret Wars avec en
plus une série dédiée à Wong et America
Chavez dans l'école des armistiques
c'est quelque chose que personnellement
je suspectais l'arrivée d'un Dr Strange
3 aux alentours des deux films Avengers
car pour moi ce dernier pourrait amener
clairement plusieurs réponses et ça
tombe bien c'est le sujet de la vidéo
d'aujourd'hui donc voilà sur ce ne
tardons pas arrêtons cette introduction
et entamons les hostilités tout d'abord
rappelez-vous de comment s'est terminé
Docteur Strange in the Multiverse of
maness notre valeur au docteur a réussi
à accompagner de Wong et américains à
stopper les actions de Wanda la Scarlet
twitch qui était corrompu par le Dark
old cette dernière c'est même
apparemment autodétruite à la fin du
film et nous retrouvons notre héros bien
plus tard sauf que il a désormais cette
malédiction dont nous ne savons pas
grand chose mais qui se traduit par un
troisième œil sur son front mais surtout
il finit par rencontrer Cléa qui vient
le chercher car il aurait
vraisemblablement causé une incursion
nos deux personnages partent donc dans
la dimension noire et fin du film bon je
ne vais pas répéter tout ce que je vous
disais dans ma vidéo dédiée à Dr Strange
2 car cela serait un petit peu lourd et
redondant mais voilà cette scène post
générique a clairement son importance en
réalité c'est complètement un teasing
pour Dr Strange 3 et je pense que vous
l'avez largement compris Steven a
toujours eu une place très importante
dans l'univers Marvel que ce soit les
comics ou les films dans le MCU il a été
une clé pour Infinity War et endgame il
est le spécialiste du surnaturel et
l'extradimensionnel comme le veut
l'institution des armistiques car il
doit protéger la Terre contre les
menaces externes et aujourd'hui alors
que dans la saga de l'infini nous étions
énormément orienté sur l'univers en
lui-même avec les Avengers qui
défendaient la terre face aux menaces de
l'espace comme le symbolisait Thanos et
bien nous sommes désormais dans les
problématiques du multivers nous savons
que la saga va se terminer avec une
gigantesque guerre multiverselle avec
des incursions etc etc et tout ça là est
bien ce sont complètement les
thématiques du personnage de docteur
proportionnelle car c'est un tout autre
concept qui a son importance pour les
problématiques à venir Cléa pour celles
et ceux qui ne savent pas c'est la nièce
de Dormammu le souverain de la dimension
noire dans les comics elle est également
la femme de docteur stranger et elle est
intimement liée à la Dark dimensions vu
qu'elle est née là-bas et qu'elle vit
là-bas avoir ce qu'ils feront dans le
MCU mais sincèrement la seule véritable
utilité scénaristique de Cléa dans les
comics c'est l'histoire de la dimension
noire et justement elle nous ramène
cette dimension dont on avait plus
entendu parler depuis le premier film de
Docteur Strange et qui dit dimension
noire bah dit également dors Mamou qui
en est son souverain et qui symbolise la
dimension lui-même et pareil ramener
dormammout c'est amener le sujet des
dimensions aussi dormammout c'est un
conquérant des dimensions et des univers
il veut accroître la dimension noire et
engloutir d'autres mondes pour devenir
toujours plus fort et toujours plus
puissant et ça c'est quelque chose qui
suit pas mal l'histoire de Dorma mot des
comics je vous invite à voir ma vidéo
sur l'histoire du personnage pour plus
de détails mais en tant que souverain de
la dimension noire Dorma mot effectué et
pas mal de conquêtes où il a assujetti
énormément d'autres dimensions qui
obéissent à son règne le MCU a pas mal
respecté l'essence du personnage mais
voilà du moins dans les comics il faut
voir Dormammu comme un leader dans les
dimensions bref tout ça pour dire que
pour moi la scène post générique de Dr
Strange 2 est clairement explicite
amener Cléa et ramener la dimension
noire qui sous-entend clairement le
retour de dormammout on se tourne vers
le concept de dimensions pour Docteur
Strange 3 maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on
fait avec ça et bien justement c'est le
moment où on rentre un petit peu dans de
la théorie et que je vous explique
comment moi personnellement je vois où
je ferai les choses par rapport rapport
à tout ça déjà tout bêtement la
problématique d'un cursion générée par
strange et donc Léa semble vouloir
trouver une solution personnellement
j'estime que Cléa a été envoyé par dor
Mamou lui-même pour chercher strange
étant omnipotent dans la dimension noire
si elle voulait s'entretenir avec
strange cela seul elle ne ramènerait pas
Steven là-bas donc c'est que Dormammu
souhaite régler lui-même cette histoire
d'incursion et en soit c'est plutôt
logique que l'entité veuille gérer ce
problème car dans ma mou si l'on suit
les sens même du personnage et bien
c'est un conquérant extra-dimensionnel
il possède son royaume la dimension
noire d'ailleurs l'existence de Cléa
dans le MCU nous confirme que tout comme
dans les comics il y a de la vie dans la
dimension noire donc voilà si nous
faisons face à une incursion cela veut
dire l'effondrement d'une ou deux
réalités tout entière si la terre 616
subit une incursion et que les deux
univers rentrent en collision la
dimension en noir sera elle aussi
détruite et par conséquent dorment et
son peuple aussi mais c'est là que nous
allons rentrer dans le côté un petit peu
technique de la vidéo car je pense bien
que vous allez me demander pourquoi
normalement et toucher par une incursion
car il est dans une autre dimension donc
voilà c'est un petit peu bizarre
pourquoi comment quoi bienvenue dans le
cœur de la vidéo nous allons enfin
parler concrètement du fonctionnement de
l'univers Marvel et plus
particulièrement des dimensions
rassurez-vous je vais essayer d'être
clair et très simple bon tout d'abord
vous connaissez tous les termes univers
réalité multivers dimensions mais le
plus important là-dedans c'est de savoir
les différencier et cela permet
clairement de mieux comprendre l'univers
Marvel le multivers c'est la collection
des réalités dedans nous retrouvons
toutes les réalités alternatives les
unes aux autres Docteur Strange 2 la
bien démontrer avec la 6016 la 838 ou
encore la réalité du sinister strange
ensuite une réalité bah c'est la
collection d'un univers c'est à dire que
dans une réalité nous retrouvons bien
évidemment la terre nous retrouvons
l'espace les autres planètes etc etc
sauf que c'est là que c'est intéressant
car cela ne s'arrête pas uniquement à ça
nous retrouvons également des dimensions
une dimension c'est un morceau de
réalité qui contient de l'espace du
temps de l'énergie et de la matière et
pour faire simple ce sont des endroits
qui font partie de la réalité mais qui
sont hors de l'univers en fait vous avez
l'univers de la terre que l'on connaît
tous et à côté vous avez les dimensions
mais tout ça on peut les ranger dans le
même sac car tout fait partie de la même
réalité et par conséquent je pense que
vous l'avez compris mais cela veut dire
qu'à l'échelle du multivers et bien ces
fameuses dimensions possède leur
variations des alternatives comme la
terre 616 avec la terre 838 etc c'est un
fonctionnement propre au comics mais le
MCU semble clairement respecter ce
fonctionnement puisque par exemple dans
watif nous retrouvons un autre dormant
face à un autre Docteur Strange ce qui
vient confirmer que nous sommes dans une
dimension noire alternative et pour
continuer là-dedans si l'on exploite un
peu plus le concept de dimension et bien
il en existe une infinité chaque
dimension est plus ou moins unique elles
peuvent être incroyablement énormes
comme celle de la dimension noire ou
bien elles peuvent abriter un simple
royaume c'est ce qu'on appelle des
dimensions de poche et c'est le cas
notamment par exemple d'Asgard et petite
particularité qui je pense sera
importante pour Dr Strange 3 mais dans
les dimensions nous pouvons retrouver de
la vie dites-vous que la terre est en
soi une dimension également et si la vie
a pu se propager là-bas et bien pourquoi
pas
Cléa vient nous le confirmer avec la
dimension noire c'est le cas notamment
de Talo de la dimension Nour des
Inhumains les royaumes
igdrasil etc etc et pire que ça encore
les dimensions peuvent abriter des
univers entiers cela fait un peu
Inception dit comme ça car ce sont des
univers dans des univers mais c'est le
cas et vous avez l'exemple parfait avec
le chant quantique qui est une dimension
abritant plusieurs secteurs plusieurs
endroits où la vie s'est développée etc
bref et dernier point qui est
possiblement le plus technique mais pas
moins important c'est que les dimensions
sont différentes en fonction de leur
emplacement prenez le cas de la terre et
imaginez que c'est le centre de tout au
niveau spatial plus les dimensions sont
proches de la terre plus elle
ressembleront à la terre en elle-même et
inversement plus elles seront éloignées
plus la vie et l'existence prendront une
forme totalement différente voilà on a
fait le tour du concept j'espère avoir
été plutôt clair et du coup c'est
important de prendre tout ça en compte
car lors d'une incursion il faut en
avoir conscience il n'est pas question
de la destruction seulement de la terre
de l'espace des autres planètes etc les
dimensions seront aussi impactées et le
truc c'est qu'ormis Doctor Strange dans
le MCU et bien personne ne s'en soucie
véritablement personne n'en a
véritablement conscience de tout ça et
justement c'est là que quelque chose
d'intéressant se dessine lors du premier
film de Dr Strange c'était justement la
découverte des armistiques du rôle des
sorciers de kamartage et des autres
sanctuaires qui est de protéger la terre
des êtres extra-dimensionnels lors du
second film du docteur on nous a apporté
le multivers et les réalités
alternatives et au final strange s'est
rendu compte que la vie était autant
présente ailleurs enfin il en avait
conscience mais il n'avait jamais
vraiment eu les pieds dans le plat et à
terme il s'est retrouvé à tenter d'aider
un autre monde là avec un troisième film
c'est la pleine conscience qu'il ne doit
pas simplement sauver la vie sur la
terre ou dans d'autres réalités mais
qu'il faut aussi s'occuper des
dimensions il n'y a pas que des monstres
ou des démons il y a aussi de simples
êtres vivants qui n'ont rien demandé
j'ai envie de faire un parallèle avec
les comics car cela traduit l'essence du
personnage de docteur stranger et ce qui
pourrait arriver d'une quelconque
manière dans son troisième film alors
qu'il n'est encore que l'apprenti de
l'ancien strange se retrouve à
confronter dormammo dans la dimension
noire sauf qu'il se retrouve face à un
dilemme de taille tu es dormammout
signifie protéger la Terre de ce
conquérant des dimensions mais de
l'autre côté si dorment est mort et bien
cela signifie l'effondrement de la
dimension noire et par conséquent de
toute la vie qui habite au final
stranger réussira à détourner la
victoire en sauvant dormammout et il lui
fera promettre de ne plus attaquer la
Terre mais tout ceci c'est pour dire que
strange maintenant n'a pas rien à faire
de la vie hors de la terre strange
cherchera toujours à défendre la vie peu
importe l'endroit où la nature mais pas
seulement car outre l'évolution de
Strange vers la pleine conscience des
dimensions etc et bien il y a moyen
aussi de relier ce troisième film avec
les futurs films Avengers déjà même si
admettons Docteur Strange connaissais
toute l'entièreté des dimensions qui
existent et bien cela ne veut pas dire
qu'il aurait accès à toutes et c'est là
où justement c'est intéressant le retour
de la Dark demon chaîne et de dormammo
Dormammu comme je vous l'ai expliqué
c'est un conquérant des dimensions
établies dans la Dark dimension et la
dimension noire c'est une dimension dite
majeure qui est encore plus grande que
l'univers de la Terre et qui abrite
énormément d'endroits et qui est
également accolé à d'autres dimensions
la Dark d'Imagine est en quelque sorte
un lieu stratégique permettant d'avoir
accès à de nombreuses dimensions
auxquelles Docteur Strange ne va avoir
accès simplement depuis la Terre et
mieux que ça encore dans ma mou si le
MCU respecte les comics à la base c'est
un faltinien exilé une race
extra-dimensionnelle et qu'en dormant a
été banni de sa dimension d'origine il a
parcouru pendant des décennies des
siècles même d'autres dimensions jusqu'à
convoiter et découvrir la dimension
noire ou en tant que souverain il a
effectué de nombreuses conquêtes ce que
je veux dire par là c'est qu'il n'y a
pas meilleur connaisseur que dorment ou
du point de vue des dimensions il est
capable d'accéder à la grande majorité
d'entre elles et il en connaît une
infinité donc si ce dernier a
véritablement besoin de Strange pour
gérer la future incursion et bien il
devra collaborer néanmoins je pense
qu'il est désormais temps d'atteindre le
point culminant de cette vidéo étant
donné la nature unique des dimensions
dans le sens où les règles cruciales de
l'univers s'appliquent différemment en
fonction de l'endroit de ces dernières
et bien il y en a certaines qui sont à
l'extérieur
la fin des temps là-bas le TVA se sert
justement de l'endroit comme une sorte
de poubelle nous retrouvons tous les
déchets issus de la suppression de Nexus
et c'est pourquoi l'endroit est bourré
de référence l'hélicoptère de Thanos le
Sphinx de Ramadan l'entreprise Kang le
casque de yellowjacket les nombreux Loki
tout simplement cet endroit est un
carrefour et par rapport au comics il
respecte une règle fondamentale du
multivers c'est qu'à la fin des temps
tous les univers se meurent et se
rejoignent car c'est l'écroulement du
multivers tout part d'un point tout se
disloque puis à terme tout se rejoint
pour s'effondrer c'est un véritable
carrefour où tous les univers se
rejoignent c'est un lieu hyper
stratégique et important et en parlant
de Carrefour tiens nous avons également
une dimension qui porte le même nom
crossroads ou le carrefour est comme son
nom l'indique un endroit permettant
d'accéder à plusieurs endroits mais
c'est quelque chose orienté plus pour
les dimensions et enfin le plus
important
le Nexus de toutes les réalités et c'est
une dimension qui existe dans le MCU il
n'y a pas meilleur endroit pour se
connecter dans tout le multivers même
dans les dimensions or des réalités et
ce à n'importe quel moment dans le MCU
et ce n'est pas le cas dans les comics
mais c'est l'endroit où réside ou à tout
le Watchers donc wati c'est dans cet
endroit qu'il observe tout c'est là-bas
qu'ultron a pu devenir une menace
multiverselle et accéder à toutes les
réalités et dans Spider-Man Noé home
nous avions la présence de failles
dimensionnelles qui ont permis au
sinister six d'apparaître ainsi que des
autres Spiderman et ses feuilles
justement sont des sortes de tuyaux hors
des réalités qui peuvent également
conduire au Nexus de toutes les réalités
puisqu'en les traversant nous sommes un
bref instant or des univers bref tout ça
pour dire que les dimensions ont leur
importance quand le Conquérant est
intéressé par ce genre d'endroit ce
n'est pas au hasard s'il est dans le
champ quantique relié au temps c'est un
endroit qui lui permettrait d'accéder à
n'importe quel temporalité de l'univers
mais depuis une dimension comme les
Landes c'est l'accès à n'importe où et
n'importe quand dans le multivers et
bizarrement c'est ce dont est capable le
TVA TVA qui a été conçu par un variant
de Kang avant de devenir celui qui
demeure dont la résidence est établie à
la fin des temps là où il peut tout
contrôler les prochains Kangs
convoiteront ce genre d'endroit et la
fin de la saison une de Loki traduit
cette idée les Avengers ont maîtrisé le
voyage dans le temps ils en ont
pleinement conscience le multivers est
installé et commence à devenir central
petit à petit pour nos héros mais
concernant les dimensions il nous faut
un expert pour la future guerre
multiverselle à venir et strange rempli
parfaitement ce rôle avec la multitude
de Kangs qui risquent d'arriver nos
héros devront faire face sur tous les
plans le passé dans le présent dans le
futur ils peuvent tomber sur des
variantes de Kang dans le multivers il y
a des variants de Kang mais c'est aussi
le cas des dimensions strange dans son
troisième film pourraient faire la
rencontre d'un ou plusieurs camps ou du
moins des vestiges d'un passage mais
surtout bien qu'americachavez apporte la
possibilité de voyager dans le multivers
il faut que Docteur Strange maîtrise le
concept de dimension pour à terme
pourquoi pas aller à la source des
problèmes mais dans tous les cas il
devra défendre la vie et ce même dans
les dimensions car lui seul le peu
d'ailleurs on parle de Strange depuis le
début mais les dimensions cela pourrait
annoncer également le retour d'une
certaine protagoniste protagoniste qui
d'ailleurs doit actuellement résider
dans une possible dimension et qui je
pense serait complètement intéressé à
accéder au Nexus de toutes les réalités
pour pourquoi pas avoir enfin son happy
mais cette théorie sera développée dans
une prochaine vidéo une vidéo un peu
spéciale puisque nous parlerons en
détail d'Avengers the candynasty et
Avengers Secret Wars
et voilà j'espère que la vidéo vous aura
plu il y avait pas mal de choses à dire
et franchement je suis content de
l'avoir enfin fait et franchement
c'était un petit peu une barrière parce
que maintenant qu'on a enfin établi tout
le concept de dimension que je vous ai
expliqué pas mal de paramètres etc et
qu'on a parlé de Docteur Strange 3 et
bien on va pouvoir maintenant entamer un
petit peu les sujets qui fâchent en
attendant n'hésitez pas à me faire vos
retours dans les commentaires si j'ai
été clair si vous avez des questions etc
tout ce que vous voulez n'oubliez pas
également le petit pouce bleu qui me
soutient énormément et puis bah
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la chaîne
pour ne pas louper les prochaines vidéos
sur ce les amis c'était tergo rock que
le lion Hart soit avec vous allez ciao
tout le monde
[Musique]